Barbie has just hit theaters and there's
already talk of Barbie too director
Greta Gerwig and leading actress Margot
Robbie have now commented on a possible
sequel to The Summer hit never before in
the history of Hollywood has a female
directed movie been able to bring in so
much money in the first few days lead
actress Margot Robbie expressed herself
rather reserved in an interview with
time about a potential Barbie follow-up
director Greta Gerwig on the other hand
is not entirely averse to the idea as
she revealed she is currently focusing
on the next few days for now but says
anything is possible she has already
spoken positively in the past about the
thought that the movie could become a
franchise Barbie is probably just the
beginning of a cinema initiative by
rights holder Mattel as variety reports
a true Mattel Cinematic Universe is
planned including adaptations of the
purple dinosaur Barney the classic Polly
Pocket the racing Toys Hot Wheels and
Thomas and friends the success of Barbie
is now surely opening up some new
opportunities for the toy manufacturer